tous les jours ou presque les mêmes
images devant l'ambassade d'algérie ses
nombreux ressortissants sont toujours
bloqués en france depuis la mi mars et
réclament une solution de rapatriement
en attendant certains doivent donc se
débrouiller de leur propre chef
c'est le cas de mehdi et humaine ce
couple arrivé à paris le 16 mars n'a pas
pu faire le chemin inverse depuis cette
date là et n'a aucune indication des
autorités algériennes toujours par là
par les réseaux sociaux tous les jours
aurait pu dire il faut il faut
remplissez ce formulaire
tu ne remplir te dire après des études
au lendemain photocopie passeport
tu es un âne et photocopie passeport qui
dit je sais pas s'ils savent rien même
gt gt presque cinq fois à charles de
gaulle à la france il ya des vols
qu'elles descendent en algérie vide
nous on comprend la situation qu'est ce
qui se passe on comprend
parce qu on a passé on a passé le
confinement ici un quartier temps ont vu
de sa situation familiale
trois enfants en bas âge restées au pays
privés de leurs parents depuis
maintenant presque cinq mois d'habitude
on vient ici pour eastman
iman ne peut retenir ses larmes et
l'avenir est pour l'instant incertain
puisque le gouvernement algérien reste
muet sur le rapatriement de ses
ressortissants
près de cinq mille algériens sont dans
cette situation en france et tous n'ont
pas la chance d'être logés se coupent a
pu bénéficier de la montée de cette
hôtelière du 11e arrondissement de paris
toute l'année je les ai trois quatre
cinq jours
mais toute l'année j'essaye quand ils
viennent faire leurs courses auxquelles
vient en visite s'est hissée qui
viennent je n'ai quand même pas les
laisser à la rue un côtier monde y a
plus d'avion
c'est là j'étais tellement persuadé pour
les ambassades que là je tombe de deux
euros quoi de voir qu'ils ne font
actuellement rien pour pour aider leurs
compatriotes
plusieurs opérations indépendante pour
venir en aide à ses ressortissants ont
été mises en place une lettre ouverte a
aussi été adressée au président de la
république
abdelmajid tebboune afin d'intervenir
pour mettre fin à ce calvaire un cri
d'alarmé pour le moment sans réponse